INDOOR KIND DINING, FITNESS
FACILITIES.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A
REQUIREMENT.
THE ONLY WAY TO PATRONIZE THESE
ESTABLISHMENTS INDOORS WILL BE
IF YOU ARE VACCINATED, AT LEAST
ONE DOSE.
STEVE: THERE YOU HAVE GOT THE
MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY
ANNOUNCING NEW RULES FOR THE BIG
APPLE MANDATING PROOF OF
VACCINATION VIA COVID TO ENTER
RESTAURANTS, GYMS, THEATERS, YOU
NAME IT, ANYTHING INDOORS.
LAWRENCE: I DECIDED TO HIT THE
STREET TO FIND OUT HOW THIS
MANDATE WILL IMPACT THE CITY
THAT’S ALREADY STRUGGLING FROM
THE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC.
TAKE A LOOK.
♪
>> SO YOU REPRESENT OVER 4,000
RESTAURANTS?
THE MAYOR JUST CAME OUT WITH
THIS GUIDANCE.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR YOU.
>> LISTEN, OUR CITY’S
RESTAURANTS HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATED.
THIS IS ANOTHER IMPOSITION
THAT’S GOING TO BE
EXTRAORDINARILY TOUGH FOR
RESTAURANTS TO DEAL WITH.
RESTAURANT WORKERS HAVE BEEN PUT
IN THE IMPOSSIBLE POSITION
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC TO
ESSENTIALLY BE THE COVID POLICE.
>> HONESTLY, I’M NOT REAL HAPPY
ABOUT IT.
I THINK THAT IT’S MY BUSINESS
WHETHER OR NOT I WANTED TO BE
VACCINATED AND I DON’T FEEL
COMFORTABLE TELLING THAT
INFORMATION TO JUST ANYBODY.
>> I DON’T THINK IT’S NECESSARY
AT THIS POINT.
YOU TAKE PRECAUTIONS.
YOU WEAR THE MASK IF YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU NEED TO AND YOU MAKE
YOURSELF COMFORTABLE.
I DON’T THINK IT’S IMPORTANT
THAT WE SHOW IT.
LAWRENCE: DO YOU FEEL
COMFORTABLE SHARING YOUR
VACCINATION STATUS?
>> I DON’T EVEN KNOW.
I HAVEN’T REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT
IT.
BUT IT SOUNDS FISHY THOUGH.
>> I MEAN HONESTLY WHY NOT IF
YOU ARE VACCINATED AND PROOF WHY
NOT.
I DON’T SEE THE DOWNSIDE TO IT.
IF YOU NOT VACCINATED CAN YOU
STAY OUTSIDE.
>> I THINK MORE PEOPLE WILL COME
TO NEW YORK AS A RESULT.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
CAN’T GET VACCINATED THEY MAY
HAVE MEDICAL ISSUES OR NATURAL
IMMUNITY HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
THAT.
>> WELL, I WOULD THINK THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO GET SOME KIND OF
PERMIT OR SOMETHING LIKE SHOWING
THAT, RIGHT?
BECAUSE IT WOULDN’T BE FAIR.
>> ’A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH A LOT
OF DIFFERENT AND PASSIONATE
VIEWS ABOUT THIS BUT THE ONE
THING THAT WE KNOW IS WE CAN’T
GET SHUT DOWN AGAIN AND IF
THAT’S A POTENTIAL THREAT, WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING NOW TO
AVOID IT.
AINSLEY: THAT’S FOR GOING OUT
THERE.
LAWRENCE: LAWRENCE MY PLEASURE.
OF.
AINSLEY: LET’S BRING IN LAW
PROFESSOR AT GEORGE WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY JONATHAN TURLEY.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: HOW DOES THIS PLAY OUT?
WILL THIS HOLD UP IN COURT?
>> IT PROBABLY WILL BECAUSE THE
STANDARD THAT APPLIES IS
RELATIVELY LOW, A RATIONAL
BASIS.
THE COURTS HAVE BEEN HIGHLY
DEFERENTIAL TO STATES.
IN FACT, THE STATE MANDATE OF
THIS KIND IN MASSACHUSETTS WAS
UPHELD IN THE EARLY 1900S.
THERE IS ALSO A LOWER COURT
DECISION INVOLVING MANDATED
MEASLE SHOTS IN NEW YORK THAT
WAS UPHELD.
BUT, IT CAN BE CHALLENGED.
WE HAVE SEEN A CHALLENGE BY LAW
PROFESSOR RECENTLY WHO HAS
NATURAL ANTIBODIES AND IS
CHALLENGING GEORGE MASON
UNIVERSITY, WHICH IS REQUIRING
HIM, AGAINST THE ADVICE OF HIS
DOCTORS, TO GET VACCINATED
ANYWAY.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE DETAILS ON THIS SO-CALLED
NEW YORK PASS.
BUT THE KEY HERE IS THAT MANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS HAVE BEEN
SUPPORTED BY PEOPLE WHO SAY WE
REALLY HAVE TO MAKE LIFE HARD ON
THE UNVACCINATED.
CNN MEDICAL ANALYST SAID THAT
RECENTLY.
WE HAVE TO MAKE IT AS DIFFICULT
AS POSSIBLE TO LIVE WITHOUT THE
VACCINE.
SO THERE IS A TYPE OF COERCED
CONSENT MODEL THAT IS KICKING IN
HERE.
STEVE: I WAS READING LAST NIGHT
ON THIS CHANNEL, SEAN HANNITY
WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW APPARENTLY
IN NEW YORK CITY ONLY ABOUT 33%
OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS HAVE GOTTEN
THE SHOT, THAT MEANS TWO THIRDS
OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN NEW YORK
WOULD BE BARRED FROM GOING
INDOORS TO RESTAURANTS AND SHOPS
AND.
AINSLEY: GYMS.
STEVE: GYMS AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
AND THIS IS GOING TO HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON THAT
POPULATION.
IT ALSO LEADS A CONTRADICTION OF
OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT ARE NOT
PRESCRIBED IN THIS WAY.
TWO PROFESSORS RECENTLY CAME OUT
AND SAID THAT GOING OUT IN
PUBLIC SHOULD NOW BE VIEWED AS A
PRIVILEGE, NOT A RIGHT.
AND THEY ANALOGIZED IT TO
DRIVING WHERE YOU HAVE TO GET A
LICENSE.
AND THAT’S HOW FAR THIS RHETORIC
IS GOING.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE IGNORING THE
FACT THAT BEING IN PUBLIC
IMPACTS OTHER RIGHTS, RELIGIOUS
OBSERVATION, FREE SPEECH, RIGHT
OF ASSOCIATION.
BUT THEY WANT TO USE THIS SORT
OF DRIVING MODEL THAT IF YOU ARE
NOT VAXXED, IF YOU ARE NOT
VACCINATED THEN YOU ARE SORT OF
LIKE AN UNLICENSED DRIVER WHO I
PRESUME HAS TO STAY IN YOUR
HOUSE.
LAWRENCE: PROFESSOR, I HAVE JUST
GOT GET YOUR REACTION REAL
QUICKLY.
DOES THAT SCARE YOU BECAUSE YOU
ARE A CIVIL LIBERTARIAN.
YOU HAVE GREAT DEFENSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION, WITH THESE LAWS
BEING IMPLEMENTED IN THE COUNTRY
AND SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF SOCIETY
IS ACCEPTING.
IT IS THAT A CHILLING AFFECT?
>> IT DOES, LAWRENCE, IT
CONCERNS ME A GREAT DEAL.
THAT’S WHY WE DON’T -- WE HAVE
DRIVER’S LICENSES BUT NOT
LICENSES FOR FREE SPEECH.
YOU KNOW, THE -- THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS OCCUPY THAT SPACE
THAT WE DON’T OCCUPY.
THEY DON’T INDULGE US, WE
INDULGE THEM.
THEY ARE THERE TO STRUCTURE THE
RIGHTS THAT WE ENJOY.
AND THAT NARRATIVE SEEMS TO BE
FLIPPING WITH SOME OF THESE
ACADEMICS.
STEVE: INTERESTING STUFF.
LET’S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
JONATHAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH